In 1922 Soviet filmmakers,
Iga bear 12 wrote about his hatred of dw
Griffith and other popular directors at
the time for making movies that he
called carbon copies of novels in
theater.
The camera is a boring objective.
Spectator watching the action unfolds
and there must be a plot relate to the
viewer with title cards.
He calls it leprose mortally dangerous
and contagious.
His response was a man with a movie
camera,
a documentary that changed the way
people made movies forever.
The caber becomes a character in the
movie showing us how we pulls off his
different shots.
He made strides in slow motion,
double exposure and split screens.
He makes his goal very clear in the
title sequence.
No sets,
no actors,
no scripts,
no title cards,
only the absolute language of cinema on
the basis of its complete separation
from the language of theater and the
novel and it's in this way of thinking
that he used the then experimental Dutch
angle,
which shows him several times in the
movie along with the other camera
innovations.
And while he was not the first to use
the Dutch angle,
he knew exactly how to do it.
The Dutch angle exploded in the 90s and
early two thousands appearing just about
everywhere from action movies to soak
commercials.
The problem comes from using the shot as
a crutch to make a boring shot.
Interesting.
Just tilt the camera.
Battlefield Earth was over 90% Dutch
angles as Roger Ebert put it.
The director,
Roger Christian,
has learned from better films that
directors sometimes tilt their cameras,
but he has not learned why the tradition
goes right up to four in 2011 director
Kenneth Brando says he was going for a
comic book look,
but I think there's more to looking like
a comic book than adding Dutch angles to
half the movie.
I also can't help but find it kind of
cheesy when it's used to make the
villains crooked,
and that's probably because of where
that idea first came from.
The dynamic joe at the school.
What I'm trying to say is these movies
don't capture the spirit of the shot.
The most important movie for Dutch
angles is arguably the cabinet of Dr
Caligari in 1920 the movie was years
ahead of American cinema at the time.
It's incredible use of shadows and
light,
angular set pieces and twist.
Ending brought expressionism from
literature and paintings to the big
screen.
This daring German style quickly found
its way into American cinema.
The extreme lighting defined the film
noir and the horror elements found their
way into all kinds of blockbusters.
I had a quad strong German and crunch by
walking up the poop.
A is burned it
fluence goes right up to Tim Burton set
pieces and character design.
He never directly sites German
influence,
but there's no doubt his work screams
expressionism and even he mixes in the
Dutch angle and his expressionistic
movies.
I like when you sit to exaggerate the
mundane like losing your bicycle.
The most crucial aspect of the cabinet
of Dr Caligari is the introduction of
subjective filmmaking.
This movie was the first twist ending in
film history when Francis is actually in
an insane asylum and his experiences are
delusions.
The movie presents its world in a
subjective way.
What we see is not reality,
but actually the subjective experience
of the narrator.
So all the movie doesn't have explicit
camera tilts.
The tilting of the set and the tilting
of the narrative introduces the idea
that movies can be hyper realistic and
more than filming traditional set
pieces.
Movies can be subjective,
so really the Dutch angle arises out of
two movements,
the Soviet experimental documentary and
German expressionism.
One movement introduced the innovative
camera techniques focusing entirely on
the cinematic aspects and the other
focused on how the theatrical and
artistic elements could be subjective
and unique.
Maybe the perfect use of the Dutch angle
comes into third man and incredible
Nawar about the black market in post
World War II Vienna,
the landscape of Vienna is the German
expressionist vision come to life with
its Jari angles and rooms landscape.
You can't help but notice the
similarities in the crooked ruins of
Vienna and the bizarre set pieces of the
cabinet of Dr Caligari in the third man,
the camera itself acts as another tilt
in the already crooked world of post
World War II vianna and sometimes the
camera doesn't even need to tell because
the street does it by itself within the
frame lines of all sorts of angles.
Add to the angle created from the camera
tilts.
The Dutch angle contributes to the
distortion already on screen giving
cinema a way of adding uncertainty that
no other art form can do,
not in theater and not in the novel,
but the crooked angles do more than
enhance the landscape.
During Holly's questioning of each
witness,
the crooked angles make their
confessions feel a bit off and reminds
you never to be quite sure who to
believe.
During Harry's monologue,
the ferris wheel tilts while the camera
holds steady creatively integrating
Dutch angles into the shot.
If fits nicely with Harry's personality
as his dialogue quickly switches from
playful justin to threatening murder.
Okay,
so look for a bullet wound up to that
ground.
The crooked vianna landscape,
ambiguous characters,
extreme lighting and plot twist,
echo the design of German expressionism
in the experimentation of the Soviet
documentary.
It's a movie begging to have Dutch
angles.
Many more recent movies used to shot in
similar ways and die hard villain.
Hans Gruber pretend he's just a civilian
during his back and forth with John
mcclane,
every shot is at least a little bit
tilted.
This medium shot on Hans is the most
tilted in the scene.
His shadow is long and exaggerated.
The camera is off center and the tension
is perfect.
As soon as John mcclane gives them a
gun,
the seem feels just like the third man.
The Dutch angle tilt adds to the
uncertainty of the moment.
We know something and we're not sure
John McLean has any idea and for all we
know he could get killed any second.
Maybe I prefer this reveal over lameness
because it's so obvious in Lima's
they're villains.
The Dutch angle feels forced.
The shots seems to fit better in moments
of tension and uncertainty when things
aren't as they should be.
It's no coincidence that a movie with
many great Dutch angles is called
[inaudible].
I liked the way they make you feel.
It's been a bit of controversy about
them as people feel that they call too
much attention to themselves.
But actually,
you know,
I just watch all the movies that are
filled with Dutch angles and you don't
realize it because they use them so
much.
It doesn't particularly mean anything.
And even all these years later,
the movies with well thought out Dutch
angles still have the expressionism then
out in back of the same apartment
buildings with these German
expressionistic alleys and they also
have the experimentation
in a producer's came in and said lucky
and I also got to shoot it four square
in case this doesn't work.
Which I certainly couldn't blame them
for doing what I ended up liking it very
much.
They even put it in the trailer.
The kind of Dutch angles I enjoy seem to
be the ones that stay true to where the
shot came from.
The English shows what makes filmmaking
unique through its emotional
manipulation of a scene.
So when your moment features the classic
unsettling nature of the cabinet of Dr
Caligari,
then it's perfect.
And when you use it just because it
looks cool,
it seems to lose some weight,
but I'm not trying to say that there's
some obvious way to use the Dutch angle.
It's a very emotional shot.
You may enjoy how it feels and movies
that I don't,
and we're both right or you could say
I'm looking too far into the shot and
the Dutch angle is just a way to tilt
the camera to make us seem interesting.
But I think if you look more closely,
you can see how the shot means quite a
lot.
The shot in many ways represents the
original intent of directors to use
filmmaking as a unique art form.
That tilting of the camera is the purest
form of subjective filmmaking.
The unease of the Dutch angle makes
cinema special because you can't do it
in theater or the novel,
and when it's used,
it pushes boundaries for what movies are
capable of.
So what I'm saying is the Dutch angle is
a perfect representation of what makes
movies better than all that other crap.
If you want to learn more about
cinematography and how to make your own
filming looked like a high budget movie,
I recommend this course by
cinematographer Ryan Booth.
He gets in depth about how the
professionals like their scenes and
shoot on location.
It's actually rare to have someone so
experience get into such detail online.
The first 500 people to click on the
link in the description below can get
two months of completely free access to
skillshare.
That's Ryan boots class and over 20,000
other classes across cinematography,
video editing,
photography,
marketing business,
and tons of other ones.
If you're not a filmmaker,
you can still definitely find a valuable
course in their thousands of classes.
I'm personally brushing up on my editing
skills in their adobe after effects for
beginners class.
Thanks for watching.
Just a bit of a break from the norm,
just a little slot in the break.
The monotony of.